une exploitation plongé dans le silence
dans le tarn et garonne le site de
maurice andral évident
les ouvriers agricoles ont été renvoyés
les machines sont à l'arrêt et les
caisses de fruits sont désespérément
vides
c'est leur seule unique prune qui s'est
sauvé de surman toute la rangée des 300
des arbres que j'ai sur cette rangée là
et le gel a été catastrophique
tous ces points noirs que vous voyez
cela et elle est brune que gelée en
avril dernier maurice s'est battu
pendant plusieurs nuits contre les
gelées mais avec -6 degrés au
thermomètre
impossible pour lui de lutter en une
semaine il a perdu 80% de son
exploitation
à cette période la récolte aurait déjà
dû commencer avec entre 250 et 280
fruits par arbre
l'an dernier ce sont 200 tonnes de
prunes qui ont été vendus cette année
maurice en viser 100 de plus bon une
adresse de 20000 euros pour une
exploitation comme la mienne c'est une
route novem héros pour moi c'est affaire
de mois seulement
je perds un train que sur la prune
300000 euros de chiffre d'affaires
je pense qu'ils auraient dû s'appuyer
sur les taux longs le chiffre d'affaires
qu'on avait fait l'année dernière et
nous donner 30 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires
parce que là je suis moi je suis obligé
d'aller au p de la banque et de faire un
nombreux s'il annonce du milliards
octroyés par l'état a fait son effet
pour de nombreux exploitants elle n'est
pas à la hauteur des pertes
un point de vue que partage la
fédération nationale des producteurs de
fruits qui se bat pour obtenir une aide
supérieur aussi bien de la part de
l'état cpt de l'union européenne un
producteur moyen en france ces 20
hectares d'arboriculture de fruits à
l'hectare un producteur fait vingt mille
euros de chiffre d'affaires donc sur une
exploitation de 20 hectares il a un
chiffre d'affaires de 400 millions et on
nous propose une avance de 20 mille
euros le producteur qui il peut pas au
niveau trésorerie il ya plus de
trésorerie sur les fermes donc vingt
mille euros comme vous avez quatre cent
mille euros de chiffre d'affaires vous
avez tout perdu on fait comment une
décision d'indemnisation rapide prise
sans concertation avec les producteurs
pour une enveloppe destinée à un panel
trop large de profession arboriculteurs
viticulteurs coopérative ou encore
expéditeurs et donc 1
partage inefficace à la fin dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire ou les
restaurateurs ont été indemnisés à 80%
de leurs pertes les producteurs en amont
de la chaîne s'estime eux les haies